grab some potato salad and smite the
enemies because we have the latest
episode of American Gods and this one is
filled with some sweet goodbyes the
episode begins with a drunk Sweeney
wallowing in his own despair after his
attempt to resurrect Laura moon didn't
turn out as well as he'd hoped he's back
in Cairo likely via his horde ability
thinking Laura may be there and he's of
the mind that the further she is away
from him the worse his luck gets shadow
strolls along wanting to know where
Laura is as well but a drunk Sweeney
mumbles on about walking on the gallows
ground a raven on each shoulder and
roots which reach from heaven to hell
he's referring to the tree gracel which
we see in the next scene the same tree
Odin pissed on two episodes ago and
which has grown considerably Wednesday
ask the other gods if they know who
their friends really are are they ready
and willing to finally go to war the
only point of contention seems to be
Bilquis who betrayed them in the first
episode resulting in the death of xariah
Wednesday then shows shadow gunner which
has recently restored its runes due to
the power of a lewd read leather jacket
he speaks a line from the regis codex
which was a book filled with ancient
Norse poems and also happened to be the
name of the theatre in the last episode
a particular note is him reciting Odin's
rune song which depicts Odin's sacrifice
of himself to himself
remember that Odin was said to have hung
himself on the tree of Yggdrasil as a
sacrifice to gain greater knowledge he
takes a branch from the tree which fuses
into the spear completing its repair he
gives it to shadow to guard after all
shadow is his bodyguard and Wednesday
says an odd line here we are the same
which could hint at their familial
relationship perhaps now shadow will
finally find out what his big role in
all of this is mama G gives Laura hard
time wondering why she's here she
instills a little fear into her by
turning into smashing Akali the chief
goddess of tantric texts texts not sex
smash onna typically holds a sword in
one hand in a severed head in the other
the head represents the ego of humanity
and the sword is used to separate us
from the ego to
the desire for and help us escape the
material / physical world and be closer
to the divine
she tells mama G she needs two drops of
blood and fused with love in order for
her potion to work but mama G says she
has the power in her all along and lures
like what the hell is that supposed to
mean
well hitchhiking Laura also sees the
glow coming from shadow and then takes a
van called the getaway van
Sweeney arrives at the funeral home in
the hopes of finding Wednesday but he's
so out of it he thinks the mourners
outside are wailing banshees he stumbles
upon Bilquis leading a service about
christ's love but the sexual undertones
are glaringly obvious as she tells the
attendees to enter the garden and taste
their fruit
this is Bilquis 'as new way to latch on
to followers Sween even says so that's
how you get your rocks off these days
Sweeney hasn't always been this way
Bilquis refers to how he used to be a
great and golden king but now he doesn't
remember his earliest memory is being
with a woman who had the sight meaning
she could see the future and she
predicted a dead woman who would seal
his fate in America it was soon after
that the grey monks changed his story
turning the fair folk into greedy little
men the grey monks refer to the
tironensian order an idiom monastic
order established in the 1100s which
shifted the perception of mad Sweeney
resulting in his loss of power but the
most important thing in this scene is
bilk was telling Sweeney he had a wife
Sweeney tells Wednesday that he's
quitting for good but Wednesday holds
the power here Sweeney can't renege on
his contract with a god what little
power he has left is held by Wednesday
and if he were to disobey he'd
essentially be killing himself and
Wednesday knows this he finishes his
potato salad telling Sweeney to finish
off Laura moon for good drunk Sweeney
yells at the mourning banshees and
bashes his bottle revealing a slew of
ants this sparks a memory about his dead
wife Yaron and daughter Moira most of
Sweeney's memories have gone forgetting
that he abandoned his people on the
battlefield resulting in a curse by the
bishop Ronan Sweeney used to be a druids
but the grey monks turned on him and
blamed them for their losses which
resulted in him going mad and being
shunned in the forest
Sweeney asked Celine why he chooses to
stay him and Jen are forced
battle because they owe it but salim
does not in many ways salim is the
counter to sweeney or as sweeney
abandoned his lover on the battlefield
salim has decided to stay back in his
memory we learned what really happened
a pregnant Yaran big Sweeney to adapt
and change to the increasing power of
bishop ronan in the church but a
stubborn Sweeney refuses believe in the
church to be slowly taking his power as
a result he tells the priest to get out
of his land
which ends up getting him cursed he
decides not to head into battle knowing
from a priest that a banshee would kill
him should he step out on the
battlefield so he decides to be a coward
and abandon his people living out the
rest of his days mad in the forest and
Sweeney wants to lend his cautionary
tale to shadow telling him not to let
Laura near Wednesday warning him about
how it feels nice to be in Wednesday's
good books now but just you wait he
warns him of the wailing banshees and
how they foreshadow death coming to the
house and curiously tells him to stay
out of the battle when it comes
something he did years ago and we all
know how that turned out for him in
search of more booze Sweeney stumbles
upon Ibis writing down the story of liu
the god king of ireland who was
eventually usurped by mother church and
made small literally into the form of a
leprechaun he speaks of his battle
against Baylor who prophesized that his
grandson would kill him but as Lille
holds up his dead head it's revealed
that it's actually Odin this hints at
why Sweeney owes a debt to him why Odin
in the Norse gods never fully took off
in Ireland and as Laura makes her way
back to Cairo we get this cool little
road sign one pointing to the old gods
in Cairo and the other to the new gods
in future city Wednesday toast to the
dismal collection of old gods when
Sweeney stumbles in and goes for gummi
air which shadow has been sworn to
protect Sweeney is defeated by shadow
but then proceeds to tell him how he was
ordered by Wednesday to kill his wife
not only that but he banged her too and
using this moment of weakness Sweeney
tries to kill Wednesday with his own
spear but is killed by shadow in the
process and with the spear lodged in his
chest he banishes it to the Horde the
one thing that was supposed to stop the
new gods for good has been lost
just like Sweeney's life and with only
one more episode of the season to go
it's not looking good for the old gods
that epic battle between the old and the
new we've been promised since episode
one looks like it may be delayed but I
want to hear your thoughts below I'll be
here for the final episode plus I've
just come out with the new Game of
Thrones breakdown so be sure to check
that out and you can always find me on
Twitter
I think story YT until next time
remember daddy loves you very much